good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is Sam Anthony and I'm your host
for tonight's lecture in book signing on
behalf of the archives of the United
States I'd like to welcome you to the
National Archives we are honored to have
with us francis stoner saunders as she
will discuss her book the cultural Cold
War the CIA and the world of Arts and
Letters a few points before we begin
when you first came in tonight you
received a program we also have some
calendars of events for May and for June
these are free you may take them home
with you or you may sign up on the sheet
outside and have these mailed to your
work or home address following tonight's
lecture at 8 o'clock we will have copies
of the book for sale miss Saunders will
be signing books at the end as well we
will make time at the end of our lecture
for some question and answers from the
audience
so why don't we get started Francis
stoner Saunders comes to us from England
where she was born in bred in London she
graduated from Oxford University and
then has worked as an independent film
producer on such documentaries as the
for our hidden hands a different story
of modernism her short story big things
was published in new writing would you
please welcome Frances stoner Saunders
let me start by apologizing for my
slightly casual appearance but American
Airlines have one of my bags someplace
so this is the best I could do
I was asked just now and I think it's
probably a good place to start why
someone who took a an English degree at
Oxford would possibly get involved with
the story involving the CIA and I have
to say briefly I shall describe the
accidental journey that brings me here
which is that nothing to do with the
suitcase by the way which is that in in
the early 90s I was researching or
developing a series of documentaries for
independent television in England whose
motivation i suppo the animating spirit
of which was to discover a different way
of telling the history of modernism in
the 20th century and we wanted to to
take art history out of the story for a
while and and look at the sociological
or the political or the spiritual
influences on 20th century avant-garde
ISM and in the midst of this rather kind
of inchoate research I was sent an
article by Eva Cockcroft which was
published in 1974 which turns out to be
a seminal piece and the title was
Abstract Expressionism the CIA weapon of
the Cold War and I figured what an earth
as Jackson Pollock got to do with Cold
War politics got a long story short I
went ahead and made a documentary which
investigated the rumor that there was
more than just an implicit link between
the success of abstract expressionism in
Europe and indeed domestically and
American foreign policy objectives
during the Cold War that's how I got
into the story as in all documentaries
half of the really good material you
have is on the cutting room floor and I
felt that you know I had the book
already I should just go ahead and write
it and three years later I realized that
was a astonishingly naive and after
spending good part of you know
one-and-a-half to two years in
crimes in Abilene Kansas and your
national archives here and just about
everywhere else in the states I realized
that I had a much bigger story than I
had anticipated so I spent the next year
and a half writing it and this is the
result now what I'm going to do tonight
is I'm going to read a tool which is
really a kind of overview a precis of
the claims of the book and also some of
the questions that it raises and I think
then we can we can go to some questions
and you know if it's lacking in detail
you know please feel free to ask me to
flesh that out in the spring of 1966 the
British poet Stephen spender wrote a
letter to Julius Fleischmann patron of
the Congress the cultural freedom and
president of the far-field foundation
these two bodies were the publisher and
financial arm respectively of encounter
magazine of which spender was co-editor
both build themselves as privately
funded independent organizations
committed to promoting intellectual and
artistic freedom but rumors had been
circulating at every literary cocktail
party in London Paris and New York that
they were not quite as free as they
appeared and spender now wanted urgent
clarification was it true he asked
Fleischman that the Congress and the
far-field foundation were financially
beholden to the American government the
allegation he continued plaintively was
putting him in a terrible position as
the editor of a magazine which
emphasizes independence after a delay of
several months during which time spend
his letter was passed from hand to hand
in Washington spender received the reply
he was hoping for there was absolutely
no truth to the rumors both the Congress
for cultural freedom and the far-field
foundation in Fleischman's words had
never accepted any funds from any
government agency less than a year later
the hollowness of this denial was
established Fleischman heir to a vast
gin and yeast fortune was awash with
money and had acquired the soubriquet
the messiness of American culture for
his abundant largesse towards the
Congress for cultural freedom and its
multitude of offshoots but he was also
legendary for his personal meanness
the stingiest rich man I've ever known
according to one contemporary spender -
had first-hand acquaintance of
Fleischmann's parsimony when his wife
had borrowed a dime from Fleischman to
make a telephone call in a restaurant
where they were dining she had been
urged in all seriousness - repaired
junky as he was known didn't forget his
debts the dime was certainly junkies but
the money he had been dispensing with
such public generosity since the early
1950s was not it was the CIA's
Fleischman was simply a conduit past the
famous pipeline that was pumping money
to the Congress for cultural freedom and
a reservoir of other organizations which
served the US government in its covert
battle for ideological supremacy in the
Cold War whilst bender appeared content
to broadcast the denial he had received
from Fleischmann others were less
acquiescent by early 1966 the
california-based ramparts magazine had
already sent out journalists to truffle
around in the undergrowth undergrowth of
the Internal Revenue Service where the
tax returns of philanthropic foundations
revealed some bizarre discrepancies
there was the ho Blitz L Foundation
whose primary purpose was listed in the
directory of American foundations as
providing support to organizations
within Texas primarily in Dallas with
emphasis on aid for the handicapped so
why on earth was it funding the Italian
magazine temple presente a publication
of the Congress for cultural freedom and
what possible interest could the Miami
District fund have in the German
magazine Der Monat also published by the
Congress ramparts was closing in on the
CIA's crown jewels for hiding behind
front men like Julius lachemann and
dummy foundations like the far-field the
CIA had from its inception in 1947
alighted upon culture as one of the
central theaters of the Cold War it was
the secret maecenas the crypto patron
behind thousands of books literally I
think it's back list runs to over a
thousand publications of books in which
it was wholly or partially involved and
scores of magazines congresses and
concerts art exhibitions and seminars
at the close of the Second World War the
United States the one out right Victor
had suddenly found itself a superpower
needing a culture to match it stared
over the wire Russia which are pursued
intellectual politics ever since
Catherine the Great and set about
acquiring worldwide intellectual
admiration and support as the Cold War
froze and ideologies divided the US
government through its intelligence and
espionage arm poured huge resources into
a cultural propaganda campaign a central
feature of this campaign was to advance
the claim that it didn't exist the CIA
was in effect acting as America's hidden
Ministry of Culture the centerpiece of
the CIA's culture camp or cultural
struggle was the Congress for cultural
freedom established in Berlin in the
summer of 1950 the Congress was an
apparently spontaneous alliance of
intellectuals and artists committed to
demonstrating the fal ability of the
Soviet Methos and the superiority of
Western democracy is a framework for
cultural and philosophical inquiry its
membership read like a who's who of the
amino series of the period Julian Huxley
Miceli and a Andre Malraux we dr. vinay
Herbert read Thornton Wilder JP Narayan
Hugh trevor-roper
James T Farrell Raymond Aron Igor
Stravinsky ignacio Saloni
Roberto Rossellini Willy Brandt Ernst
Reuter a Jair Herbert read Malcolm
Muggeridge James Burnham Sidney hook
Arthur Schlesinger jr. after curse ler
Mary McCarthy Diana and Lionel trilling
Norman Thomas Upton Sinclair John
Steinbeck Allen Tate Robert Penn Warren
the list is endless like Agatha it is
endless I just realized he goes on and
on it even features Jackson Pollock that
he was probably drunk when he joined
honorary presidents were Bertrand
Russell Benedetto crochet John Dewey
Karl Jasper's Salvador de Madariaga
Jacques Maritain and Reinhold Niebuhr
it's achievements not least its duration
were considerable at his peak the
Congress for cultural freedom had
offices in 35 countries employed
hundreds of personnel published over 20
prestige magazines including its
flagship encounter held art
owns the owned a news and features
service organized high-profile
international conferences and rewarded
musicians and artists with prizes and
public performances amongst to avoid
another list are just amongst these
where the Boston Symphony Orchestra
abstract expressionism the Mozart iam
Academy Orchestra of Salzburg Tanglewood
Music School International pen the
Philemon occur hungaricum the film
versions of Animal Farm in 1984
Metropolitan Opera Berlin cultural
festival and many many other
organizations and events were indirectly
and whether they knew it or not and
whether they liked it or not linked to
the Congress / cultural freedom or or
indeed other fronts run by the CIA this
prolific activity made the Congress for
cultural freedom a compelling feature of
Western cultural life from the platforms
of its conferences and seminars and
across the pages of its learnig reviews
its members acquired an audience for
their views which no other organization
except perhaps for Moscow's common form
could deliver just as right McDonald's
so memorably described the Ford
Foundation the Congress for cultural
freedom was a large body of money
completely surrounded by people who
wanted some for the CIA the Congress
codenamed QK Opera was the prize in its
propaganda assets inventory a register
of the fronts on which it knew it could
rely known unofficially as witness
Wurlitzer after Frank Wisner head of the
office of policy coordination the
nickname reveals the agency's perception
of how these assets were expected to
perform at the push of a button wizna
complainy Tunney wish to hear across the
world in early 1966 word reached the CIA
that ramparts was pursuing leads to its
web of cultural organizations Richard
Helms deputy director for plans
immediately appointed a special
assistant to pull together information
on ramparts including any evidence of
subversion and to devise proposals for
counter action by Mae Helms was feeding
the White House with the inside dope on
ramparts as part of a campaign to smear
the magazine its editors and
contributors
much of the information supplied by
hounds had been produced from trawling
through agency records additional dirt
was supplied courtesy of the FBI Helms
who was convinced that ramparts was
being as used as a vehicle by the
Soviets
ordered a full investigation of its
financing but failed to turn up any
evidence of foreign involvement after
reading through the ramparts file
presidential assistant Peter Jessup
penned a memo with a memorable subject
line a right cross to the left temple
which read in view of ramparts
dedication to smearing the
administration and the murky background
of its sponsorship one might think that
some agency of the government would be
pursuing the threads involved here a
week later the magazine Human Events ran
a smear under the title the inside story
of ramparts magazine its journalists
would dismiss two snoops eccentrics
ventriloquist's and bearded new left NYX
who had to get out of Vietnam fixation
signed by one mmm
Morton quote the pen name of an expert
on internal security affairs on quote
the article bought all the hallmarks of
a CIA plant as did a newsweekly piece of
the same week who really managed the
ramparts and an article in The
Washington Star both of which announced
serious doubts about the bona fides of
brand parts which was described as not
only a muckraker but a muckraker with a
malevolent motive
the CIA did everything it could to sink
ramparts quote I had all sorts of dirty
tricks to hurt their circulation and
financing Deputy Inspector General
Deputy Inspector General Edgar
Applewhite later confessed the people
running ramparts were vulnerable to
blackmail he said we had awful things in
mind some of which we carried off we
were not in the least inhibited by the
fact that the CIA had no internal
security role in the United States
amazingly given the awfulness of the
CIA's intentions ramparts survived to
tell the tale just as it feared it went
ahead and published its investigation
into the agency's covert operations the
magazine's findings were swiftly picked
up in national newspapers and an orgy of
disclosures followed leading one
commentator to conclude that
before very long every political society
philanthropic trust college fraternity
and baseball team in America will be
identified as a front for the Central
Intelligence Agency at about the same
time a series of articles appeared in
The New York Times exposing a wide range
of covert action undertaken by the Dark
Angels of American government as stories
of attempted cooze and mostly botched
political assassinations poured onto the
front pages the CIA came to be
characterized as a rogue elephant
crashing through the scrubland of
international politics unimpeded by any
sense of accountability amidst these
more dramatic cloak-and-dagger exposes
came details of how the American
government had looked to the cultural
brahmins of the West to lend
intellectual weight to its actions the
suggestion that many intellectuals had
been animated by the dictates of
American policymakers rather than by
independent standards of their own
generated widespread disgust the moral
authority enjoyed by the intelligentsia
during the height of the Cold War was
now seriously undermined and frequently
marked the constant sokrati
was falling apart the center could not
hold and as it disintegrated so the
story itself became fragmented partial
modified sometimes egregiously by forces
on the right and indeed on the left who
wished to twist its peculiar truths to
their own ends ironically the
circumstances therefore which made
possible the revelations contributed to
their real significance becoming
obscured as America's anti-communist
campaign in Vietnam brought it to the
brink of social collapse and with
subsequent scandals on the scale of the
Pentagon Papers and Watergate it was
hard to sustain interest or outrage in
the business of culture camp which in
comparison seem to be fluff on the side
history wrote Archibald MacLeish is like
a badly constructed concert hall with
dead spots where the music can't be
heard what I've attempted to do in this
book is to record those dead spots it
seems to me that it's the duty of
historians to seek a different acoustic
to look for a tune other than that
played by the official virtuoso of the
period
gore Vidal that wonderful charlatan has
described recent American history as a
phenomenon where the agreed upon facts
are not as numerous as professional
historians like to think blinding them
to fictionalize a new there's official
fictions that have been agreed upon by
altogether too many two interested
parties each with his own thousand days
in which to set up his own misleading
pyramids and obelisks the purport to
tell sometime let's not settle for the
agreed-upon facts then but rather
challenge them this then in brief is the
story have tried to piece together by
wandering through the misleading
pyramids and obelisks drawing on an
extensive highly influential network of
intelligence personnel political
strategists the court press
establishment and the old school ties of
the Ivy League the incipient CIA started
from 1947 to build a consortium whose
double task it was to inoculate the
world against the contagion of communism
and to ease the passage of American
foreign policy interests abroad the
result was a remarkably tight network of
people who worked alongside the agency
to promote an idea that the world needed
a Pax Americana a new age of
enlightenment and it would be called the
American Century the consort in which
the CIA built up consisting of what
Henry Kissinger has described as an
aristocracy dedicated to the service of
this nation on behalf of principles
beyond partisanship was the hidden
weapon in America's cold war struggle a
weapon which in the cultural field had
extensive fallout whether they liked it
or not whether they knew it or not there
were few writers poets artists
historians scientists or critics in
post-war Europe and indeed America whose
names were not in some way linked to
this covert Enterprise unchallenged
undetected for twenty years
America's spying establishment operators
to service as sophisticated
substantially endowed cultural front in
the West for the West in the name of
freedom of expression defining the Cold
War as a battle for men's mind its
stockpiled a vast arsenal of cultural
weapons
journals books conferences seminars art
exhibitions concerts and awards
membership of the consortium which
managed all of these activities included
an assorted group of former radicals and
leftist intellectuals whose faith in
Marxism and communism had been shattered
by evidence of Stalinist totalitarianism
emerging from the pink decade of the
1930s warned by Arthur Koestler as an
abortive revolution of the spirit of
misfired Renaissance a false dawn of
history their disillusionment was
attended by readiness to join in a new
consensus to affirm a new order which
was substitute for the spent forces of
the past the tradition of radical
dissenter where intellectuals took it
upon themselves to probe myths
interrogate institutional prerogative
and disturbed the complacency of power
was effectively suspended in favor of
supporting the American proposition
endorsed and subsidized by powerful
institutions this non-communist group
became as much a cartel in the
intellectual life of the West as
communism had been a few years earlier
and it included many of the same people
there came a time when apparently life
lost the ability to arrange itself says
Charlie citrine the narrator of Saul
Bellow's Humboldt's gift it had to be
arranged intellectuals took this as
their job from say Machiavelli's time to
our own this arranging has been the one
great gorgeous tantalizing misleading
disastrous project a man like Humboldt
inspired shrewd nutty was brimming over
the discovery that the human Enterprise
so grand and infinitely varied had now
to be managed by exceptional persons he
was an exceptional person therefore he
was an eligible candidate for power well
why not
like so many Humboldt's those
intellectuals who had been betrayed by
the false idol of communism now found
themselves gazing at the possibility of
building a new Vemma an American vie mom
if the government and its covert action
arm the CIA was prepared to assist in
this project well why not that former
left-wingers should have come to be
roped together in the same enterprise
with the CIA
is less implausible than it seems at
least to Europeans I think maybe
Americans are much more familiar with
this kind of paradox there was a genuine
community of interest in conviction
between the agency and those
intellectuals who were hired even if
they didn't know it to fight the Cold
War the CIA
the CIA's influence was not always or
often reactionary or sinister wrote
Arthur Schlesinger jr. if my experience
is leadership was politically
enlightened and sophisticated this view
of the CIA as a haven of liberalism
acted as a powerful inducement to
collaborate with it or if not this at
least to acquiesce to the myth that it
was well motivated and yet this
perception sits uncomfortably with the
CIA's reputation as a ruthlessly
interventionist and unaccountable
instrument of American power this was
after all the same organization that
masterminded the overthrow of premier
Moscow day in Iran in 1953 the ousting
of the arbenz government in Guatemala in
1954 the disastrous Bay of Pigs
operation in 1961 and the notorious
Phoenix program in Vietnam it spied on
tens of thousands of Americans harassed
democratically elected leaders abroad
plotted assassinations denied these
activities to Congress and in the
process elevated the art of lying to new
heights by what strange alchemy then did
the CIA manage to present itself to
high-minded liberals like Arthur
Schlesinger jr. as the golden vessel of
cherished liberalism the extent to which
America's buying establishment extended
its reach into the cultural affairs of
its western allies acting as the
unacknowledged facilitator to a broad
range of creative activity positioning
intellectuals and their work like chess
pieces to be played in the great game
remains while the Cold War's most
provocative legacies the defense mounted
by custodians of the period which rests
on the claim that the CIA's substantial
financial investment came with no
strings attached is still largely
unchallenged amongst intellectual
circles in America and Western Europe
there still persists persists a
readiness to accept as true that the CIA
was merely interested in extending the
possibilities free and democratic
culture
expression we simply help people to say
what they would have said anyway
goes this line if the beneficiaries of
CIA funds were ignorant the fact the
argument goes and if their behavior was
consequently unmodified then their
independence as critical thinkers could
not have been affected this was exactly
the line peddled vice Gloria Steinem
quote the CIA's most important impact
was that it made us unafraid to go ahead
and do what we thought was right she
declared in 1967 when her own cover in
the CIA funded independent Research
Service was blown it increased not
diminished our freedom of action she
added Gloria Steinem said William Colby
former director of Central Intelligence
has wrong has been wrongly accused of
being a CIA tool in her work the CIA
only helped her and others go to foreign
political conferences where she
presented the kind of independent
spontaneous positions and image that is
truly representative of America's
freedom I should say William Colby went
on the record with this quite a way back
when I interviewed him shortly before he
fell headlong into the swirling waters
of the Potomac although I can assure you
my interviewing is in no way related he
refused to go on record with this this
was said of the woman who was important
enough to the CIA to be assigned her own
case officer Steinem was one of 250
students sponsored by the agency to
attend youth festivals in Moscow Vienna
and Helsinki in the late 50s and 60s and
early 60s her relationship with the
agency clearly illustrates how it moved
from blank checks support to operational
use of its assets the students we use
for missions such as reporting on Soviet
and American personalities and observing
Soviet security practices one student
attending the 1957 World Youth festival
in Moscow was instructed to report on
Soviet counterintelligence measures and
to purchase a piece of Soviet
manufactured equipment these details by
the way were released in the Church
Committee report of 1976 such
operational use was not limited to
students artists athletes leaders and
specialists in all cultural fields who
were traveling to Europe under the
auspices of the fulbright-hays Act which
expressly for bad
years of cultural exchange programs were
also frequently used funded openly by
Congress they were covertly deployed by
the CIA
if Steinem felt that her freedom had
been increased and not diminished by the
CIA's involvement with her
anti-communist activism why has she
refused for years to be drawn on the
subject her 1968-69 entry in Who's Who
list her as a member of the board of
directors of the independent research
service yet subsequent additions make no
reference to her directorship and reduce
a period of employment with the service
from three years to one another
misleading pyramid official documents
relating to the cultural cop this was
not simply an act of altruism the
individuals and institutions subsidized
by the CIA were expected to perform as
part of a broad campaign of persuasion
of a propaganda war in which propaganda
was defined by national security
directives as quote any organized effort
or movement to disseminate information
or a particular doctrine by means of
news special arguments or appeals
designed to influence the thoughts and
actions of any given group a vital
constituent of this effort was
psychological warfare which was defined
as the planned use by nation of
propaganda and activities other than
combat which communicate ideas and
information intended to influence the
opinions attitudes emotions and behavior
of foreign groups in ways that will
support the achievement of national aims
further the most effective kind of
propaganda was defined as the kind where
the subject moves in the direction you
desire for reasons which he believes to
be his own
it's useless to dispute these
definitions they are littered across
government documents the donae
of American post-war cultural diplomacy
CIA agent donald jameson intended no
irony when he told me that as far as the
attitudes that the agency wanted to
inspire through these activities are
concerned clearly what they would like
to have been able to produce
were people who of their own reasoning
and conviction were persuaded that
everything the United States government
did was right there's not a question
then of people being coerced into saying
what they didn't believe it's not a
question of people writing articles for
encounter magazine or tempo presente or
quadrant or even American journals here
like partisan review which very
indirectly receives CIA funding at one
point to boost its circulation it's not
a question of them simply acting a
simple Ventrella quest for the American
government on the contrary it's about
the inseparability despite appearances
to the contrary a free behavior from
institutional patronage it's what you
might describe as the inevitable
relations between employer and employee
in which the wishes of the former become
implicit in the acts of the latter
National Committee for a free Europe
crusade for freedom free Asia committee
Free Europe University Radio Free this
radio free that Congress for cultural
freedom in the mid-1960s the joke was
that if any American philanthropic or
cultural organization carried the words
of free or private in its literature it
must be a CIA front
even the far-field foundation many CIA
people that I spoke to said you know the
jokey mantra inside the agency was it
was to call it the far-fetched
foundation because by the sixties pretty
much everybody could guess who was
behind it clearly however by
camouflaging its investment the CIA
acted on the supposition that his
blandishments would be refused if opined
off if offered openly do you think I
would have gone on the encounter payroll
in 1956 had I known that there was
secret US government money behind it
Dwight MacDonald angrily asked the man
CIA as it turns out who had put him on
the payroll if you do we are really out
of contact one would hesitate to work
even for an openly government-funded
magazine I think I've been played for a
sucker
Stephen spender later thought it would
be amusing to write a funny Gogol like
story about a man who whatever he did
and whoever his employer Fanty was
always been paid for by the CIA
he should have known what kind of
freedom can be advanced by these
deceptions it was Harry Truman under
whose presidency the CIA was established
before his death said secrecy and a free
democratic government don't mix freedom
of any kind certainly wasn't on the
agenda in the Soviet Union were those
writers and intellectuals who were not
sent the gulags were last sued into
serving the interests of the state it
was of course right to oppose such
unfreedom and I can't stress this enough
there's no doubt in my mind where I
think in any reasonable person's mind
that was right to oppose the Soviet
Union but I think what I described in
the book is is a larger picture than
that and it's right to oppose unfreedom
but I also asked the question with what
means was there any real justification
for assuming that the principles of
Western democracy couldn't be revived in
post-war Europe according to some
internal mechanism or for not assuming
that democracy could be more complex
that was implied by the lauding of
American liberalism to what degree was
it admissible for another state to
covertly intervene in the fundamental
processes of organic intellectual growth
a free debate and the uninhibited flow
of ideas in the countries of its allies
did this not risk producing instead of
freedom a kind of freedom where people
think they're acting freely when in fact
they are bound to forces over which they
have no control
the CIA's engagement in cultural warfare
raises other troubling questions did
financial aid distort the process by
which intellectuals and their ideas were
advanced were people selected for their
positions rather than the basis of
intellectual merit and what did Al
Fakher Schley mean when he lampooned the
International academic Corps girl
circuit of intellectual conferences in
symposia where reputation secured or
enhanced by membership of the CIA's
cultural consortium how many of those
writers and thinkers who acquired an
international audience for their ideas
were really second-raters ephemeral
publicist whose works were doomed to the
basements of second
and bookstores how many others drunk too
heavily at the trial their creative
energy sapped by the weight of their
expense account what most irritated us
wrote Jason Epstein some years ago was
that the government seemed to be running
an underground gravy train whose
first-class compartments were not always
occupied by first-class passengers the
CIA and the Ford Foundation among other
agencies had set up and were financing
an apparatus of intellectuals selected
for their correct Cold War positions as
an alternative to what one might call a
free intellectual market where ideology
was presumed count for less than
individual talent and achievement and
where doubts about established
orthodoxies were taken to be the
beginning of all inquiry it had at last
become clear how bad a bargain the
intellectuals had made that it could
never have been in the interest of art
or literature of serious speculation of
any kind or even of humanity itself for
them to serve the will of any nation it
will perhaps be another 50 years before
we discover whether the influence still
exerts whether the CIA still exerts
influence over the cultural affairs of
this and indeed other nations on the
lobby wall of the CIA's headquarters at
Langley Virginia is engraved this for
instant John's Gospel the truth shall
make you free it's time it did
we have time for questions from the
audience applauding and comer is a
flagship of Congress what extended your
research and turned up evidence
Frank whenever they would push button
which affect the selection writers
contributed to was able to influence the
selection of articles subjects which
were treated three the degree to which
contributors to encounter aware of where
the money was coming from to be
therefore would be in a relationship
relevant to your employer and 44 and for
the extent to which the CIA actually
affected editorial decisions in the
magazine and five what extent the CIA
mr. choice of music
perform Boston 71 live riding it down so
hang on okay first did it influence the
choice of writers what was the first one
selected to write for the magazine's
okay well when the Congress for cultural
freedom was set up in 1950 the CIA had a
very direct influence on the personnel
who were selected to to run it it was a
man called Nicholas Nabokov who was the
second candidate put forward to be sort
of the official impresario if you like
well if you'd let me finish I'll tell
you the first candidate was Louis Fisher
who was not approved at Washington for a
whole variety of reasons principally
because he was American and it was
thought that he was this made it too
overtly kind of an American organization
rather than a European one you won't
find louis fisher in the God that failed
which was published in 1949 and you
won't find him writing for any of the
Congress magazines I would say that I'm
not entirely clear what what the
agency's objections were to Louie Fisher
but he's not he's not there and as an
anti-communist and as a prominent member
of the non-communist left least in
America one might ask why because there
are papers relating to the choice of
candidates for those roles in the early
days the Congress of cultural freedom
and the same applies to the editors as
for writers it was for the editors to
decide of the individual magazines for
example to decide who they were going to
commissioned to write a piece very
rarely was anybody you know dropped
because of orders from Washington I mean
the point is that it wasn't necessary
these were people who were who were
selected for you know for the
correctness of their positions you
wouldn't have had an editor of Encounter
magazine which was set up in 53 who was
openly opposed to the Korean War just
wouldn't have happened when I asked Tom
Braden who set up the international
organizations division whether or not
the CIA had a right to veto they said
that they did have a right to veto and
that if someone had stood up at the
Congress for cultural freedom in Berlin
in 1950 and wanted to make a speech
against the Korean War they wouldn't
have done it I mean there would have
been veto
the point is that that right to veto was
very very rarely exercised which you can
take to be an indication if you like of
how Washington I think was effectively
happy with with the magazines and and
generally the kind of you know
publishing activities that it had that
it was funding
Dwight McDonald's peace famously in 1956
which was submitted to encounter
accepted by Stephen spender and
subsequently rejected accepted and then
finally rejected it has always been said
that the reason it was rejected was
because it was a bad piece it was a kind
of instinctually Buttle of America
you know guided by right sort of you
know nutty romanticism for Europe
subsequent to spending three months in
Tuscany because that can you know turn
anybody's head as we all know but the
literature that I for the correspondence
that I found speak specifically of his
points about career and that they felt
that it was extremely bad an almost Pro
Soviet propaganda to reprise the claims
of Eugene Kincaid who had written
extensively and commissioned report but
for the US government of the collapse of
morale amongst US soldiers prisoners of
war in Korea this was information that
it was decided in Washington woods not
going to be pumped that was the reason
that article was not published so when
people say to me well you know there
aren't enough examples of articles being
axed or of people being vetoed or people
being corrected it's not about coercion
or veto it's about simply setting up an
organization of publications which have
all sorts of cultural bona finders which
by the by publish you know memorable
some of the most memorable essays of the
period Isaiah Berlin six pieces on
Russian literature was published in
encounter I mean that's not a you know
you do a demolition job on that on the
achievements in terms of you know great
argument and great pieces of these
magazines but you know this was the
cultural side of magazines that also had
a kind of political agenda
marbeth well-written wires connecting
themselves would want it published is
there evidence the significant numbers
of writers who didn't have why the Pens
wanted to publish monthly published in
the counter and were not the I spent a
lot of people who didn't feature an
encounter but who were sort of of the
period who told me they would never go
anywhere near encounter because they
knew they wouldn't be published that's
that's not a scientific answer to your
question but the feeling was the you
know Hugh trevor-roper said in 1950 that
he thought the Congress for cultural
freedom was being backed by the
Americans he wasn't bothered by that he
went on to he was with the Congress and
he wrote many times for the fair
encounter magazine but there were others
who who had the same feeling early in
the 50s and who were uneasy with it and
who chose not to write for encounter my
point about about all of this is it's
not so much a question of editorial
control although it's clear that
guidance was issued at a certain level
and was then passed down I mean I have
many documents relating to guidance that
was passed on to the editors they could
then fight it they can then say I don't
want to do something about you know
highland dancing in Scotland because you
know I'd rather run a piece about the
European market for example but this was
a you know clearly give-and-take situate
these people were not Patsy's nobodies
Patsy's or what I would say to you is
that I think the Jason Epstein quote
goes some way to describing what what
members of the independent left in
Western Europe felt which was that they
weren't being given a chance to compete
fairly on a level field in their non
communist activities with subsidized non
communist activities which had grown
into a kind of you know sub profession
eligos a lot of applications a lot of
rumors reports from is from one person
to be a conservative standpoint I cost a
lot of robust evidence acidic and
clarify just like his hair and I can
direct you technician ethics in Spanish
it means you measures which God is
believing smell restoring force is a
help to you even without knowing any of
them maybe some of them is there's a
reason for generalization but what you
see the robustness of the evidence to
suggest that many of these people were
doing something like that
the first question is how much they do
generalize even assuming assuming a big
emphasis are robust based on that how
far can you generalize to say
scoot over doing that again I chose a
mutual [ __ ] sighs I assume I move the
far as to agree that some people dress
up right at you when you mention like a
fuller Hayes scholarship or and some of
the school they went to Europe or ever
maybe they were sighted over here I
never for my scar by the way and it's
fascinating because a lot of us know
that I know I have a much
it'll take some forward Christian
operation and in what an asterisk in
person ahead so I'm going to say be
careful because I'm sure a lot of course
academia so the reason for grateful
famous for powerful if they might be
they might use all that abuse articles
on purpose is to have be careful because
there can you make some stuff like that
of a CIA vacation iris yes a lot of
sensations tourists and people you seem
to you face is a beautiful wonderful
sunlight how much can you move what
pixel can remove also new movies
yes perhaps you haven't read the book as
you say and I but I absolutely take your
points and I think that you know there
is there is naturally a danger when you
do particulars you know some big names
of sensationalism and I've noticed in
quite a few of the and some of the
reporting of this book and in some of
the reviews by you know fairly
prestigious reviewers both for and
against the book that you know very
simple mistakes have been made by miss
reading of what I say and not
misinterpretation but miss reading
people confuse the details that I give
about the American military government
cultural programs in Berlin all of which
are available for inspection in the
National Archives here with later
programs or projects that that the CIA
were involved in which had nothing to do
with American military government I
found that that you know the two case
scenarios have been confused let's let's
talk about Fulbright the evidence for
the Fulbright comes from the Church
Committee report of 1976 and I recommend
you read it this was the most compelling
and and serious analysis sustained
analysis of US intelligence operations
anyone who reads this report I think
will come away with it with it with a
clear feeling about what the
distinctions are between as you say
evidence and supposition or
generalization and I took the church
report committee as one of the kind of
backbones together with a couple of
other committees reports including the
Cox committee report in 1952 which is
astonishing in its level of detail about
the CIA's intrusion into the field of
philanthropic foundations and gives
facts and figures numbers of foundations
involved how much of this percentage of
their spending was going to CIA projects
I use those as a kind of you know
backbone and I think you know one
assumes of what one can rely on
congressional committee inquiries I
interviewed people who had never been
interviewed about this before I was very
careful not to use hearsay or allegation
I don't believe in it you know I've read
several books that deal with that deal
with the Communist Fifth Column in
America in which it said it doesn't very
recently been the publication of the
Metro can archive of an invaluable
historical document which has been
published here and
in the UK in which people are named as
KGB spies with absolutely no effort to
talk to them to ask them whether they
have a response to the allegation before
it's published and on the basis of what
one KGB officer says I didn't take on
the basis of what one CIA agent told me
anything to be de facto truth if I had
you know pieces of paper or other people
who said it you know when you ask who
knew who didn't know when you know 50
people tell you I know that so-and-so
knew because we sat down and talked
about it and here's an exchange of
letters we had in 1957 or whatever it
might be then you know there comes a
point at which you have to make a
decision about about the nature of
evidence which you know and I agree I
think one should be you know constantly
aware but you've got to be careful too
because your your argument would suggest
that you know there is no history
there's no way of writing into these
these complicated stories and trying to
kind of you know
well that's I'm saying that's a
confusion that I think could also arise
by by by erring too much the other side
that there are some people they are
doing that
and I took up this ring with them I'm
just saying that's on a Sunday which at
that point I think you need to come up
with more fast starting to work I think
with respect to me to read the book
before you say I haven't researched it
properly
that's you know we could make a general
point about this but notice that leave
us negative evidence just about how much
can you generalize again I can only that
yes operation of the whole book to
understand what you are trying to do
I do think scanning is not a scientific
way of researching and it's not a
scientific way house inside education
the social sciences has kept the social
sciences and welcome any news on both
sides
you won't like it me llamo Rebecca
spices whatever good on the right side
here with bio meteorologist thank you
okay yeah let's say I'd like to ask the
open-ended question throughout the
global back when Phyllis native Robert
Oppenheimer I became a member of the
American Congress for cultural freedom
in 1954 after he lost his security
clearance there in the United States
he also said I always involved with
Eugene Myers wife in setting up the
Mount Kisco conference nothing
for the columns defeated just if the
robber had died he was
during scheduled go to Paris I think he
was then the plaintiff director I think
for the Congress of cultural freedom and
then he had a thought that because
but can you comment anything more rather
than diamonds roll say in Congress in
the significance of it as well other
members of the Congress I think that
Oppenheimer's joining in 1954 was
certainly viewed by members he joined
the American Committee for cultural
freedom and I think it was you know
viewed as a positive thing I make very
clear that the American Committee for
cultural freedom display
despite its really checkered history
because it had appalling divisions
internal divisions it was really split
between kind of hard-line anti-communist
there's a famous anecdote you know of
Dinah trilling standing up at a dinner
party and saying none of you men are
hard enough me and they're all kind of
you know with her but between that
between the of the hardline communists
and communists in the American Committee
in the modders and this this history if
you like is something that I show
through through a lot of documentation
Arthur Schlesinger papers and his own
words on this matter a fairly revealing
so I think that Oppenheimer's joining in
54 was seen to be a very positive sign
because it gave an air and real weight
to the American Committee of cultural
freedoms title which was that it was
fighting for cultural freedom and as
initially Xango himself said after one
particularly nasty episode where the
Congress the American Committee got
involved in sort of harassing somebody
or trying to get them out of their job
he said you know a committee for
cultural freedom can never in being
Magnum honest so I think Oppenheimer's
joining was certainly significant in all
the American Committee for cultural
freedom papers that I research and I
researched well I understood at the time
to be the full collection which is in
the Talmud library here in New York
whether I'm subsequently told by Daniel
Bell that some boxes have been held back
but in the papers that I research
there's very little mention of
Oppenheimer I think he was one of those
many members who who I do point out in
the book I mean omit there's clearly
distinction between activists who are
you know involved in day-to-day running
of these committees and and that their
agenda and their minutes and everything
else and those like Oppenheimer who are
members I think later on there's a quote
from Stuart Hampshire the British
philosopher at the end of the book where
he remembers talking to Oppenheimer in
67 once most of these exposures had come
out in which Oppenheimer took a ferry
sort of sang when approached much like
Isaiah Berlin in which he said well you
know
okay it happened so we kind of all knew
about it big deal which was you know the
sort of lesser fare attitude of many
people but I think you know in the case
of Oppenheimer having not been there may
be people here incorrectly but having
not been directly involved in any sort
of you know organizational running of
any of these programs was was lending
his name to an outfit which I think
fundamentally he approved on assistant
editor at foreign policy magazine here
in DC I was walking outside the building
and there's an agreement on the building
it's his past is prologue so I think
it's incredibly appropriate that you're
giving your talk here at the National
Archives or believe everything that's
tangible about our history but given
that background I touched on this a
little bit at the very end of your talk
when you said it may be 50 years before
we know if these kinds of things are
still going on but it's sort of become
appreciating cultural politics you have
the Americanization of global culture
and then you have the subsequent
backlash to that particularly in
continental Europe so I would like for
you to cast your note a little farther
if you can and try to fill that
disconnect between your book and what's
going on now the backlash and and the
Americanization of culture and how you
see the two related I mean I think
you're right i mean the continental
European perspective of this book indeed
end of this story will be I think to a
large degree different than it is here I
mean new people are genuinely even of an
older generation to mine are genuinely
quite shocked or a stand at all or even
if they're positively sort of shocked if
you like bye-bye
the extent to which the cultural Cold
War was fought by America in Western
Europe I don't think that this
necessarily is contributed to a kind of
a backlash or a rise of anti-american
feeling there's always periodical is a
kind of extraordinary cyclical thing
that there's anti Americanism you know
surfaces and then and and then you know
ebbs away in Europe on on a cyclical
basis I mean sometimes you can see it
directly related as in the mid-60s with
Vietnam to specific moments of
ideological tension or financial or
economic tension I think that with NATO
now there's quite a lot of anxiety
amongst Western Europeans about
Americans America's role in NATO about
whether or not we want to be part of an
organization that has such a strong
American role but there are people who
feel equally strongly as I think it's
really hard to generalize I think what's
what makes it very hard to generalize is
that the kind of this very inchoate and
sort of purposely it seems to me
disorganized and unnamed Seattle
Washington major in London sort of you
know under the surface groundswell of
opinion that seems to be against
globalization and Glenn and against
capitalism and against any kind of
certificate against the media or any
think there you're seeing something of
the kind of residual anti Americanism
that you know that the new left in
Western Europe felt in the 60s and 70s
but I think it's I think it's sort of
getting beyond left and right which is
probably a good thing and I really do
feel that the kind of the ideology is
you know that lot the 20th century in
this kind of you know steel embrace do
seem to be shattering what's alarming of
course is to know you know if left and
right is no longer this that you know if
those that are rather pious polarities
are no longer relevant what is and I
think that's why you know governments
are now increasingly worried about about
these movements because they don't you
know it's quite it's not the new New
Left is it I don't know what you know
it's not it's kind of hard to define the
world after them about 3/4 of the way
through I founded that at the end
interesting migration of the facts and
actually hardly work everything's been
amazing however I understand
to me points of difference first as we
know that we were lectured the day
thought that the struggle that the Cold
War was over it was over to be cost and
yet I am not comfortable in your book
with a persistent subtext there were
some certain moral equivalence here
because I would first like to point out
two things that many of these are.this
were in the counterculture here
domestically reverse the Soviet artists
were state-sponsored
and you even spent one case in your book
for someone
- Tyler Perry ground complain increase
CIA overseers
with any story - has been able to do the
same probably not um
the second point is as I said I am
convinced by by the evolution first met
regarding the snail involvement and
since then an economist that was
converting the the dollar amounts into
ninety nineteen eighty billion I was
astounded by by the size of the amounts
nevertheless don't you exaggerate the
significance of CIA involvement in
winning the future of Cold War because
what about the role of calling with
commercial films for instance because
he's speaking personally when I was
growing up in Southeast Asia and I saw
propaganda films from huppin's China me
Simon films think we were so much better
this
this exaggeration of the rule of thumb
has Procopio freedom that we had in turn
are in direct response I think in a very
valid point that you know one of the
reasons I think the CIA but for a brief
kind of flirtation through one or two
semi agents in Hollywood with the you
know the movie business I mean they knew
this but this this project using no I
think the answer the question is no I
don't exaggerate it because what I make
clear is that what the Congress for
cultural freedom represented was a
serious alliance of intellectuals leave
aside the institutional you know CIA
background from a committed to
preserving high modernist achievements
they were not people who enjoyed as as
the writings of you know of all of these
individuals even now will show very
clearly who enjoyed anything of mass
culture they did not like Elvis they did
not like Blue Jays you know one of the
biggest fears was if you read having
crystal now one of his major fears was
was not that you know people weren't
going to read in counter magazine or or
that the Soviets were going to Newcastle
we were going to knew that it was that
you know Elvis and blue jeans were going
to win the Cold War and that that would
meant that even if it was an American or
non Soviet victory that you know the the
the those elite in high cultural values
and ideas would not have won and that's
essentially what has happened this war
is a kind of you know at one level an
incredibly heroic battle to try and
defend high culture from from from the
threat not just of mass man in the
totalitarian Soviet Union sense but you
know the famous use of of mass culture
in the in the Dwight MacDonald you know
it's here in America send so it was kind
of a domestic battle there as well as
you know just just the the dread and the
justified dread of the Soviet paradigm
being imposed in terms of culture it was
evident here right before their very
eyes and noses and this is something
that you know they write about you know
compellingly now this is this seems to
be the real guiding project of of their
lives actually is this is this action
against those sort of you know
breaking of the the floodgates and that
you know the the Philistines are inside
obligation abroad was easy then gone but
did we project was mister missus I
didn't think I mean I think the real the
real target was absolutely Western
European intellectuals who were
non-communist but not necessarily
persuaded that they wanted to be
pro-american so there was a distinction
there and there were certainly the
neutral s or the waverers who were at
the third you know the so-called Third
Way which emerged interestingly out of
the European movement which in itself
was heavily backed by the CIA but it was
it was knows absolutely about it was you
know it was not just about opposing the
Soviets it was about also and you know
kind of creating a groundswell of
approval and asserting the merits of you
know American culture in the post-war
era you know if you have an enormous
Imperial burden which America had which
it had acquired in the Senate in the
aftermath of Second World War you need a
culture to go with it I mean I think
that's not you know I think it's just
instinctive this is what happens
and craziest editor between the back
sunny copies and also angry border
questions thank you all very much for
coming